Financial stress on the parents
translates into physiological stress in
the children they didn't inherit
anything in terms of a disease they're
just reacting to the environment people
call Dr gabomate the people whisper
legendary thinker and best-selling
author he's highly sought after for his
expertise on addiction stress and
childhood development the evidence
evidence linking mental illness and
childhood adversity is about as strong
as the evidence linking smoking and lung
cancer and the average physician doesn't
hear a word about that it's astonishing
I can give you the example of a Donald
Trump I mean his father was a psychopath
you are the enemy of the people go ahead
for him these were not choices so much
as survival techniques and that's the
mark of a traumatized child a denial of
reality
what do I have to understand about your
earliest years to understand you
my grandparents were killed in Auschwitz
and my mother and I barely survived and
then my mother to save my life gives me
to a stranger in the sense I guess that
I'm being rejected and abandoned because
I'm not good enough how did that rear
its ugly head throughout your life in a
number of ways it's the traumas I Define
it is not about what happens to us it's
about what happens inside of us as a
result of what happens to us it's
costing us in terms of our physical
health our relationship our mental
health and so on how does one go about
correcting that it's a multi-layered
answer first of all
before this episode begins I just want
to say a huge thank you to all of our
new subscribers 74 of you that watch
this channel didn't subscribe before and
we're now down to about 71 so that helps
us in a number of ways that are quite
hard to explain but simply the bigger
the channel gets the bigger the guests
get so if you haven't yet subscribed to
the Diary of a CEO if I can have any
favors from you if you've ever watched
the show and enjoyed it it's just to
please hit the Subscribe button without
further Ado I'm Stephen Butler and this
is the Diary of a CEO I hope nobody's
listening but if you are then please
keep this yourself
my dear little man
only after many long months do I take it
in hand the pen
so that I may briefly sketch for you the
Unspeakable horrors of those times the
details of which I do not wish you to
know
those are words that your mother wrote
into her diary in the 1940s during the
Holocaust
in April of 1945 three months after the
Soviet Army expelled the Nazis from
Budapest which is where we live so she
was referring to
the previous year and the beginning of
that year late 1944 and early 1945. and
in those diary entries she's addressing
many of them to you directly as a baby
sure to Dairy to me directly
um as if it was like a account of my
life
addressed to me
you talk so much in in your in all your
books um and much of your work about the
importance of that early context it's
really been I mean the center point of
all the writing that I've read recently
and I know because it's
it's so evident in everything that
you've done that that's been a key your
own early context has been a key
inspiration for why you've taken such a
an interest in these topics what was
your early context what do I have to
understand about your earliest years to
understand you
so it's just a fact about human beings
that
the template that forms us will affect
how we see the world how we understand
ourselves how we relate to other people
and um the early template is earliest
months even in Europe already in the
womb we're being affected by the
environment but certainly in the early
years when our brain is being formed and
our personality is taking shape
and so that forms our world view now my
worldview was in my sense of self was
shaped by the fact that
at two months of age when I was two
months of age the German Army occupied
Hungary Hungary was the last country in
Eastern Europe where the Jewish
population had not been exterminated and
that was our turn
the day after the German Army marched
into Budapest which was March the 19th
to the 1944 the day after my mother
called the
pediatrician to say would you please
come and see Gabor because he's crying
all the time and the doctor said of
course I'll come but all my Jewish
babies are crying
and so that the fact is that when
mothers are stressed or in pain the
infant feels all that and takes it
personally and it becomes part of their
template for how they view the world
so that was that year that's when that
year began in which my grandparents were
killed in Auschwitz and my father was
away in forced labor and my mother and I
barely survived and
a story I've told many times but
that's where my brain is developing and
that's when I'm forming my sense of
myself
and then my mother to save my life gives
me to a stranger and I don't see her for
six weeks the sense I get is that I'm
not wanted then I'm being rejected and
Abandoned and because I'm not good
enough
that's
how my life began
so your mother gives you away for five
to six weeks yeah in order to sort of
save you from starvation and you know
ghetto that that she was going to right
that's right this is after after your
grandparents were killed in our switch
by yeah the Nazis
um how do you know in hindsight that
that that moment of those six weeks
created that sense of Abandonment in you
I wouldn't say it's just about that one
moment children very much view
themselves
through their interactions with their
parents
now first of all I had no father because
he was gone I hadn't hadn't seen him
except very briefly I'm one of the month
old but there was no father in the
picture my mother was grief stricken and
terrorized and full of Woe and worry
about what's going to happen to us and
just the the task of surviving each day
she's not playful with me she's not
smiling at me very much she's worried
looking she's stressed looking
the infant takes everything personally
that's just the nature of the infant as
infants were a narcissist we think it's
all about us so when things are great
hey we're great but my mother is unhappy
it's because she doesn't want me or I
can't make her happy or I'm inadequate
so that separation from my mother
certainly set a template for some of my
relationship interactions with my spouse
decades later but the sense of not being
good enough and and and and being
responsible
that was inculcated in me throughout
that whole first year of life so much so
that in this book The Myth of normal I
actually talk about a an experience with
psychedelic mushrooms at the with the
therapist this was not that long ago
seven years ago maybe
um
when I'm at least 70 years old and
I'm in this therapeutic session with the
cytocybin the the medicine
and the therapist and I know that I'm 78
70 years old and I know this is a
therapy session and I know her name and
I know
who I am in the world but at the same
time I'm experiencing myself as a
one-year-old baby and she's my mother
and I start crying tears come down to my
my face and I say I'm so sorry I made
your life so difficult
now that was an unconscious memory of my
sense of myself as a one-year-old that I
made my mother's life so difficult
because that's the way the baby
interprets it
so even if your mother loved you which
mine did infinitely not that she always
treated me the best way possible but she
did love me and um
can you imagine what a great Act of Love
even giving me to a stranger in the
street would have been for her you know
but because of her own unhappiness I can
only conclude that I'm not good enough
and it's my fault
it's 70 years old having that psilocybin
experience coming to that realization or
having that sort of
um having that response to your
therapist where they take the role of
your mother and you're a one-year-old
how does somebody at 70 years old go
about correcting that that sort of
interpretation you had of that traumatic
early early event
well by bringing up to the conscious
level
them and I noticed that sense of guilt
or responsibility in me I say oh
that's what it's about so it's it's a
meaning
see traumas I Define it is not about
what happens to us it's about what
happens inside of us as a result of what
happens to us
and so the wound in my in trauma means
wounds the wound in this case is my
sense of deficiency or not being good
enough not being worthy enough once I
realized that oh this has got nothing to
do with anything except this
interpretation that I made with my own
experience all those years ago then when
I noticed it I can no longer believe it
I don't have to any longer be a a
subject
to that interpretation of myself in the
world so awareness is one step it's not
adequate but it's an essential step
towards um letting go
that one belief that you weren't good
enough yeah how did that
rare its ugly head throughout your life
it
um made me a workaholic physician
because they had to keep proving my
worth
and it doesn't matter no I don't know if
you ever had an addiction but the nature
of it is that we're trying to get from
the outside something that only can
arise and fulfill us from the inside
so
when you're looking at from the outside
it's addictive because you get it
temporarily but then that internal
emptiness that hole never goes away so
it has to be filled over and over and
over again it can only be done so
temporarily so it becomes runaway
addictive so then you know work becomes
an addiction because I keep trying to
improve my worth
and it doesn't matter how many times
you know I I may show up in a positive
way at the beginning of Summer life at
the end of somebody else's life or any
time in between
it never fills that emptiness that my
sense of lack of worthiness creates
so that's one major shows up
another way it shows up is if
um in my relationship
I don't feel as satisfied
my wife doesn't
please me the way I like her too
um
then I get angry but why am I getting
angry
I'm getting angry because it's my sense
of not being good enough that's being
now revealed
it gets uncovered this this this this
this self-accusation
um but I get angry at her because her
job is to make me not feel that you know
we get into this relationship
four kinds of reasons some of them are
conscious some are not some are positive
some are come out of trauma in my case
I want that relationship to prove to me
how good I am
so when it isn't proving that then I get
upset with my partner you know well
except the Gap is inside me not inside
it's not coming from her so it shows up
it should have been my parenting it
shows up all over the place
I mean I think both of those examples
sound a lot like me especially the first
one yeah
um the second one as well but yeah what
sense in the sense that I I'm definitely
a workaholic and I thought I think in
the earlier phases of my life I like
sacrificed everything in this pursuit of
becoming a millionaire and and having
all this stuff and really getting this
validation sacrificed meaningful
connections everything in the pursuit of
this one thing well part of the toxicity
of the culture that I
talk about in this book is that it
actually rewards that kind of emptiness
or that or that desperate
seeking to to to to fill that emptiness
because because you know you get
rewarded you make a lot of money a lot
of people admire you you get to feel
good about yourself mind you my guess is
that good feeling is only temporary at
least if my example is any
guy that you know that feeling good
because somebody from the outside values
you it's only a temporary self for the
for the wound that's inside
but the world actually rewards it you
know so you're a workaholic doctor great
you make more money and all these people
respect you meanwhile you're holding
yourself on the on from the inside and
you're not available for your family you
know so that that's part of the
craziness of this culture and it's like
the it's like the hedonistic treadmill
in this in a sense because you just
never enough is never enough as you say
yeah so the last achievement needs to be
surpassed by a greater achievement for
me to get an applaud or a clap I've
never really made the connection that
the reason why I'm a workaholic is
because I am trying to prove to the
world that I'm enough but I think that
it's entirely true yeah so in your class
like like race and class in this Society
of inequality are certainly traumatic
potentially traumatic inputs as I
pointed in this book and you know to to
the degree that it affects people's
physiology you know but also then I
don't know your family version or what
kind of relationship you have with your
parents but there also may have been a
sense
like I got with my mom for you know
reasons and and for whatever it might
have happened in your family maybe you
got the sense as well that even in your
family origin you weren't
good enough somehow so my mum would
scream at my dad for like seven hours a
day my dad would just sit there okay and
so my early memories of like looking at
my mum and dad are this kind of
violent verbally not like physically
this incredibly stressful screaming one
person screaming at the other that's
what I remember but from reading what
you've written in this book and from
what you've said now
I actually might have learned
sort of learned to that I was the
problem to some degree your children
interpret it that way that's just the
whole point that's what I mean about
kids being narcissists that I don't mean
that in the negative sense I just I mean
actually they think it's all about them
so if your mother is unhappy
it's your fault
you know and you're not good enough
so then you have to go out there and
work to prove yourself to prove to the
world and to yourself that you're good
enough so that going back to your first
question about how these things show up
in our lives that's how they show up
and so 12 years old you you emigrate to
Vancouver yeah
um by 28 you joined the medical
profession yeah and you spend the next
32 years roughly working in well at 28 I
went back to medical school actually I I
took a detour I was a high school
teacher for and
um and then I was 27 28 when I started
medical school at age 33 I think I began
my medical
career of 32 years and in those 33 years
what what was your practice what did you
specialize in what did you focus on
so I was a family physician
which meant I delivered a lot of babies
and I looked after people's problems
from beginning to the end of life I also
worked in palliative care I was the
director of a unit at the hospital which
looked after people with a terminal
disease
and I did
that was 22 years or so of my practice
28 22 years
and then then I switched gears all
together and I went to work in the
downtown east side of Vancouver British
Columbia which is more North America's
most constantivated area of drug use we
have more
people coming from anywhere in the world
are shocked by what they see there are
thousands of people in the streets
injecting selling using inhaling
ingesting drugs of all kinds and people
have suffered the consequences of
drug use in a society that doesn't
understand drug use so it punishes it
and excludes it also sizes it so people
get HIV from Dirty needles and and
hepatitis C so
this is the population often they're
homeless so that's the population I
worked with for 12 years till the end of
my medical work
that experience working with patients
that were in palliative care so that's
for anybody that doesn't know that's
patients that are approaching the end of
their life that have terminal illnesses
and that are aware that they're going to
to die
what did that experience teach you
it took an acceptance of one's
lack of
lack of omnipotence as a physician
because you go into the you want to cure
people you want to you want people to
heal
and now it takes the tremendous
exceptions to say you know we've reached
the limit of our knowledge
and that doesn't mean we can't help
people but we certainly can't cure them
you know and so it taught me how to be
with the inevitable
and and and when you're working with
people who are
in the process of dying about I mean by
the way who isn't in the process of
dying you know but but people whose time
is more limited than the rest of us
acceptance you learn a lot of acceptance
it challenges you to do your best
when you know your best isn't going to
be saving anybody's lives but it's to
help people live a life of
as little suffering as possible and as
much dignity as possible
so it really challenges the best parts
of you to show up patience acceptance
um intuition personally taught me a lot
to listen to people interesting enough
people really want to be heard when
they're dying
they want to make sense of their lives
they want to tell their stories then I
want their stories to be heard
and so I listened a lot I just sat by
the bed so I don't know it isn't
and all that
when you listen did you
did you hear any themes relating to
regret or things that actually mattered
because I always imagine in if I was
given such news that my life was coming
to an end and there was an approximate
date it would be quite a powerful way of
finally realizing what truly matters and
what never did you know people who react
to their impending death in different
ways so there were some people who just
fought it to the end you know they
didn't really want to accept it but most
people
were more along the lines that you
describe where they really get to see
what's important and so I mentioned this
a number of times it sounds strange and
I don't recommend it but I've had
patients say to me doctor I don't know
how to tell you this and I can't even
explain it perhaps but this illness
that's going to take my life is the best
thing that have happened to me
and but by men they meant a couple of
things by it they meant what you just
said about finding out what's really
important in life in this book The Myth
of normal lying to you a young man
called Bill pie wrote a book called
blessed with a brain tumor
in a Hot Hog what kind of blessing is
that so I said I asked will what's the
blessing and he said it made me
appreciate every moment it meant every
time I talked to somebody this I knew
this might be the last conversation I'm
gonna have with them so it better be a
human genuine interaction
so there was that aspect of it the other
aspect of it was that
again my view is as I pointed in this
book and in previous Works who gets sick
and who doesn't isn't isn't exactly
accidental they were certainly
personally patterns based on traumatic
experiences in your childhood that make
disease more likely
and people very often realize that
throughout their lives they had
abandoned who they were they lived the
life that didn't wasn't meaningful for
them
and
are on that they reconnected with
themselves in an authentic way and that
seemed to be worth a lot to people
again I don't recommend that way of
going to reconnect with yourself but
people have certainly I certainly saw it
so those are the two big lessons
after your 33 years in medical practice
um you you described that you had a bit
of a you kind of tuned into a creative
calling which was writing well I began
to write when I was a physician so my
first book on ADHD after I was diagnosed
with it was published in 1999 now so
that was 23 years ago now so I began to
write and even before then I wrote
Because I wrote uh cons for newspapers
but yes there was a time in my life
where the writing impulse which had been
with me all my life was stifled and and
and and and
um stymied
and so was I because I had this
frustration in fact they had the sense
that there's something I needed to
express
but I didn't know what and they didn't
know how and at some point I realized oh
yeah I need to write so that began
before I finished medical practice but
it certainly
um
has been essential to my ongoing
unfolding as a human being
I was so compelled by that when I when I
read about that because um
I've started to really understand the
value of creativity in all of our Lives
regardless of whether we have the luxury
of being called an artist or not and so
what in your view is the importance of
well you're you're singing my tune here
if I may say it that way because
um I called in this book uh there's a
great Hungarian Canadian stress
researcher called Janus celi a c-l-y-e
and Celia is the one who actually coined
the word stress in the sense that we use
it today and he's the one that showed in
the laboratory how stress diminishes the
immune system and this this organizes
the hormones and and ulcerates the
stomach and all this kind of stuff but
so now you also said then I quote him
here what is in US must out what is in
us most out
that we all have to follow our key of
your urges in the way that nature
prepared for us otherwise we can be
hopeless hopelessly hemmed in by
frustration I'm paraphrasing him very
closely
so
we are created an image of God I mean as
you know what do religious views are but
that sense that we created an images of
God means that we are creators because
the essence of God is creation
in fact we call God the Creator and we
call the result of that creation
if we're created then if we're if we're
offshoots
of that creative dynamic in the universe
then it means that it's in us to create
and whatever form that takes I mean you
know you don't want to see me
do art you know unless you
I can do a pretty good stick figure you
know but but I'm married to a nurse
um
so that Community doesn't have to take
the form of formal art but it does it if
it takes some flow of something that's
inside you that needs to come out
otherwise as Celia says you get
hopelessly hemmed in by frustration and
so in that sense everybody's got that
creative urge and that may take the form
of social intercourse it might take the
form of gardening I don't care communion
with nature
athletic expression I don't care what
but it but but there's somebody
everybody's got it and if people don't
realize they have it it's only because
life is him demand and they're too busy
and sometimes they are trying to make a
living or trying to survive or too
disconnected from themselves but it's in
all of us and to the extent that we
don't give it expression we suffer
one of the things that really hems it in
is um
is the prospect that we might not be
good at it because we think to express
ourselves creatively we kind of join a
competition of sorts and that's that's a
trap we can fall into so if I'm gonna DJ
I need to become a good DJ yeah but in
Social comparison or else I don't want
to but what I've come to learn is in
fact the act of DJing alone in my
kitchen at midnight is is the reward
regardless of outcome or whether there's
a crowd there it's just me and my dog
listening that is the expression is the
reward not the achievement or the medal
that I might get although yeah not the
external well look look I went through
that in the writing in this book so here
I am this is you know
the writer who writes about you know
trauma and you know healing and all of a
sudden I'm in a panic because I'm
writing a book and I realize that the
problem was that you talked about
identifying with your work so I had
identified with this book so the problem
wasn't a book
because let's say I write the book and
it's not a success I mean okay big
headline in the Sunday Times book not a
big success you know like how big of a
deal is that in the history of the
universe
but if I identify with the book
and it's not going well then if the book
fails then I'm feeling as a person which
then goes back to my very earliest uh
concern about not being worth it you
know so once I disidentified
I said no this is just a book it may be
a good book it may be an important book
maybe a book that doesn't hit the mark
but it's only a book and how it goes
says nothing about me or my worth
once I could decouple that then I could
confidently and much more comfortably go
back to the writing of it but I went to
that crisis it seems like a bit of a
paradox that this the lack of self-worth
would would motivate someone to to
create great things because they want
the approval but at the same time make
the process so agonizing because their
self-esteem seems to be on the line yeah
all their sense of self-worth is on the
line
well that Dynamic was in me once I
realized that I let go of it you know so
it didn't it didn't dominate me in the
end and uh honest to God by the time I
finished the book
I'm not just saying this in retrospect
it's it's the best seller now in several
countries but
I actually said to myself and I meant it
now I've done the book
that's what matters
I've said what was in me to say
how the world reacts
I can't control and it doesn't actually
matter on a fundamental level it's not
that I don't want this book to be
accessed I mean success of course I
wanted to sell 10 zillion copies but
that doesn't Define my self-worth or a
high function in the world how I feel
about myself honestly it does not and I
I understood that by the time I finished
working on it
so once it's done it's out there doing
its work or not doing its work
but I don't have to hang my own sense of
self on how the book does
because at that point that's an outcome
you can't control right so trying to
control that would be yeah anxiety and
yeah oh yeah well you can't control it
no
10 years this book yeah took you to
write took me to prepare it took about
three years to write yeah you describe
it as a calling yeah the myth of normal
yeah what four words to to sort of pull
people into in some way summarize uh 550
odd page book why why those four words
why that phrase
can I post from one to find a quote on
my cell phone 100 yeah yeah I just
so this is um are you familiar with the
rokovic artoli uh Echo totally yes okay
yeah so Tony lives in Vancouver like I
do and um in one of his books he says
the normal State of Mind of most human
beings contains a strong element of what
we might call dysfunction or even
Madness you know so
um in medical
um parlance uh normal means healthy and
natural so there's a normal range of
blood pressure
normal
temperature it's a range outside that
range there's no life there's no health
either too high or too low you're gone
so normal means it's it's equivalent
with synonymous with healthy and natural
however we make that same assumption
that the audience Society what we used
to what we call normal is also healthy
and natural which is a myth because I'm
saying that in this Society what we
considered to be normal is neither
healthy nor natural in fact it's hurtful
to us so that we're using the word
normal
in in a way that
doesn't apply
in the narrow medical sense
it's accurate but in a broader sense
that which we're used to in this Society
be considered normal is just not good
for us you know and Norm is kind of a
statistic or it's a kind of a
um average so if everybody you have a
dog if everybody in London mistreated
their dogs and if you didn't then you'd
be abnormal you know so it's a myth to
say that what is normal is healthy and
natural that's what I mean by the method
normal that's one one thing I mean the
other thing I mean is
if we understand that the actual science
of the unity of everything I'm not
talking about spiritual Insight here I'm
talking about you know physiological
science that are physiology and
psychology is very much affected by our
life experiences being in utero
childbirth early childhood and
throughout the lifetime
it also follows that illness and health
are not individual attributes they're
actually manifestations of our
relationships and our situation in the
world and and our history
that also means when the circumstances
are abnormal
you expect people to be sick
you know just as if
you gave animals something that wasn't
healthy for them they'd be sick that'd
be what you'd expect
so
this idea that the people who are ill
either physically or mentally abnormal I
say no these are normal responses to an
abnormal set of circumstances
and
rather than being sort of those abnormal
ones and the rest of us it's really a
spectrum they were all pretty much all
on it so in those three senses this idea
of normal is is a myth and it's one that
keeps us from
seeing reality
and we're all an abnormal in some way
yeah so if you maybe my maybe my
attention is different maybe my you know
my my interpersonal relationships are
abnormal but in some way I'm going to be
abnormal as it relates to treatments how
do you think that the medical profession
and the psychological profession would
respond differently if we removed this
idea that there is a normal how would
our approaches change to treating people
hmm
well that's
it's a multi-layered answer
um first of all we would recognize that
our diagnoses are not explanations for
anything
so you know I've been diagnosed with ADD
you know legitimately so as my first
book was on it
um
but but it doesn't explain anything
so so I do not easily very easily you
know and sometimes when I don't often
and I don't want to but you know
unless I'm highly motivated
so so you might say this person has ADD
how do we know because he Tunes out a
lot
why is it doing a lot this is
because it turns out a lot so so first
of all we have to understand that our
understanding of normal and what's
outside the normal they don't doesn't
explain anything
they can they can describe if you
describe my mental functioning as that
of somebody who's got an automatic
tendency to tune out you'd be accurate
so the description
it's helpful as an explanation as to why
this person isn't behaving quote unquote
normally
it doesn't explain anything not if you
understood
that I spent my infancy
under very difficult circumstances where
I was very stressed because of all the
stuff I already talked about and that
tuning out was a normal response
to to those circumstances as a way of
protecting myself from the stress of it
all and this is happening when my brain
was developing
then you understand there's nothing
abnormal about by tuning out in fact it
is the normal response to a set of
abnormal circumstances
so that's the first point and I could go
through the same kind of dialectic with
all manner of physical and mental
diseases by the way so-called
the
second point is why do you say so-called
um
well look the disease model is
as long as we understand it's a model
it's okay and we think it describes
reality fully it doesn't so
um
for example
um because you talk about mental
illnesses
and we're assuming that there's a kind
of definite pathology there just as in
rheumatoid arthritis you can describe
the inflammation of the joints and
the blood levels of certain antibodies
being abnormal and
hormonal levels being disturbed you know
we're making the same assumption in
mental illness there's no such evidence
in mental illness there's no
physiological parameters that you can
say somebody's got mental illness
there's just been a study a few months
ago of thousands of band scans
of people with mental illness diagnosis
there's nothing diagnostic about them
about the brain scans it's not like I
can take an x-ray of a lung and say that
this is this lung is got what we call
consolidation or or fluid indicating
inflammation
there's nothing like that and mental
diagnosis there's no blood test you can
do and so on so illness
is a is is a
is a model I mean it might
yeah somebody's really depressed
even suicidal perhaps and they might
need pharmacological Intervention which
will really save their lives that may be
true
and in that sense you may say that
they're ill
as long as we realize that this is a
construct that we're applying here but
there is no actual measurement of that
that's at all similar to what we call
physical disease
but even a physical disease we make
certain assumptions
um for example somebody has rheumatoid
arthritis no
that nothing wrong with that statement
on the face of it but there's an
assumption there
the assumption is that there's this
thing called rheumatoid arthritis
and there's this person called me and
this person has this thing no you know
the example I often give here's my cell
phone I'm holding it in my head I have a
cell phone it's not part of me it says
nothing about me it just it's a discrete
object its nature doesn't depend on my
nature
nothing
is that true about rheumatoid arthritis
or is it more true to say as I found out
that this is a condition that shows up
in people with certain life experiences
and certain ways of functioning in the
world and that because of the science
document the unity of mind and body and
the
impossibility of separating the activity
or emotional apparatus from seeing our
immune system because it's all one
organismic unit
therefore the when the immune system
turns against the body as it does in
rheumatoid arthritis damage system
actually attacks the body
is that a thing that's got a life of its
own or is it a process that's happening
inside that person because of certain
aspects of their lives
now if I say it's a thing that happens
to you then that thing has got a life of
its own and that's why most doctors see
it they see somebody with rheumatoid
arthritis they say okay this is the kind
you've got this is what's going to
happen this is this is the only thing we
can do is this is to mitigate the
symptoms
I find that's not true I find that the
rumor that by them not just I find it
the science finds it that rheumatoid
arthritis is very much related to stress
and Trauma and the more stress there is
the more likely it is to flare up and if
people deal with that stress if they
know how to prevent it their illness
abates
which means that it's not a thing that's
separate it's a process that happens
inside them
this is a subtle concept though I'm
wondering if I'm explaining it clearly
no you are and it's really making me
question how much we misunderstand the
relationship between the mind and the
immune system yeah because
that's the real that's the important
connection to understand if you if you
are to accept all the things you've just
said yeah which we don't we don't
understand I don't think typically we
understand that my mind and my immune
system have such a close relationship
well the the there's a whole new science
that studies those relationships it's
called psychoneuraminology which studies
the interlinked unity of the emotional
apparatus of our brain and body with the
immune system with the nervous system
and with the hormonal apparatus I mean
it's just so obvious
I could change your hormonal state in
this fifth second right now without
touching you just by screaming at you
and threatening you that would
necessarily create a change I mean it's
just clear their emotions are
inseparable you know and and the other
funny thing is well several funny things
how do we treat most conditions in
Medicine by the way inflammations if you
go to a dermatologist with the infinite
skin
if you go to a rheumatologist with
inflamed joints you should go to a
gastroenterologist with inflamed
intestines
if you go to a respirologist with
inflamed lungs if you go to a
neurologist with the inflamed nervous
system is in multiple sclerosis they're
going to give you steroids
the steadily inflammation the water
steroids they are stress hormones
and you would think that as Physicians
we would ask ourselves gosh we're
treating everything with stress hormones
the stress maybe have something to do
with this condition
then when you look at the scientific
literature yes yes and yes so the
um there's a Great Canadian physician
actually United by Queen Victoria one of
the great medical teachers of all kinds
Sir William Osler and he said in 1890
that rheumatoid aristritis is a stressed
during disease
the the French uh neurologist Jean Matan
charcoal who first described multiple
sclerosis he said this is a stress
driven condition
and since then there's been so much
research
so
what I'm saying is that this this way of
looking at
what we call disease is a process
is so much more accurate scientifically
actually and understanding the Mind Body
unity and then you know naturally when
people are traumatized that has a huge
impact on their physiology their
psychological trauma is a huge impact on
their physiology it's just science
but its science that's not taught to
Medical teach medical uh doctors it's
just for some strange reason well the
average physician never hears a single
lecture about say trauma and his
relationship to illness and yet the
studies internationally thousands of
them
showing those relationships
so there's this strange gap between
science and and medical practice but it
would it would change medical practice
for the better
because what would happen if you went to
a physician and and you presented with
your symptom and they'd say okay look
we'll give you such as medication to
deal with your symptoms and then let's
look at your life
in the context that you live it and see
how that the stresses that you may be
taking on the traumas you may be
carrying might be affecting the
physiology of your body
no they don't have to be all trauma
therapists to do that they just have to
raise the question
and they start and then to begin the
inquiry that'll make a huge change to
that person's life and to their disease
process
and clearly to their kids lives as well
because I remember reading in your book
about the uh the study with the rats
yeah
um and how they could you tell me about
that study how the stress study with the
rats and how the parents
um treatment of a child
impacted their stress response and then
also they passed that on which I thought
was yeah that was a very interesting
study it was done in Canada
um at McGill University
um I think maybe something in the last
20 years
early 2000s I think
and they looked at her mother rats
interacted with their infants their
newborns and some and this is a process
called grooming
in which the mother rad licks the infant
earned apparent very uh perennial a
perineal area you know in the genitalia
this is shortly after birth this mother
rats you start licking their infants
some other rest did it in a more
efficient and caring kind of way than
other mother rats
those that had the better kind of caring
the better kind of grooming go to be
calmer
and responded to stress in more
functional ways than those little rats
who
as neonates had not been given that same
kind of
efficient and quite as caring grooming
foreign
the brains of those adult rats who had
been groomed one way or the other as
infants the stressed apparatus was
different certain receptors for the
stress hormones so one of them could
call themselves more easily than the
other
what was interesting is you might say
well that she's genetic the calmer
mothers passed on their genes to the
infants no they didn't because if you
took the infants of mothers who groomed
beautifully and put them with mothers
who didn't and conversely it took the
infant Rats of mothers who
didn't groom so well but you put them
with mothers who did
they change it changed the brain for the
adult it changed the brain it changed
the genetic functioning not the genes
okay but the genetic functioning this is
called epigenetics how genes are turned
on and off by the environment and then
those mother and those rats who are
going well as infants doesn't matter
what the original mother was but those
are actually going well they went on to
groom their infants
in exactly the way they had been groomed
so this is how we passed on our
parenting stuff
from one generation to the next both
behaviorally but also through the
turning on or off of certain genes
so in essence the how nurturing our
parents were has a big impact on our own
ability to handle stress positively or
negatively oh absolutely and then we
passed that down I stressed up answer
how they reacted to her own stress as
infants you know that has everything to
do with her brains handle stress later
on
and so some people just don't handle
stress very well they don't handle a
frustration very well
you should have seen me this morning at
the hotel when the swimming pool didn't
open in time you know
but I I was a lot better than it might
have been years ago you know uh but yeah
our stress responses are very much
programmed by our early uh developmental
experiences
speaking about our early experience is
the first word in the sort of subtitle
of your book is the word trauma
um it's a word that I've I've talked
about a lot on this podcast and I've you
know I've had a lot of people here that
have opened up about their traumas how
do you define trauma I know Society has
defined it in its own way but how do you
define it the word
I I Define it very specifically
um it's not something bad that happens
to you it's not some no it's not that
you know I went to this movie last night
and I was traumatized no you weren't you
were just sad or you were had some
emotional pain but you weren't
traumatized
trauma means a wound that's the literal
meaning of the word it's a Greek word
for wounding so trauma is a
psychological wound that you sustain
and um it behaves like a wound so on the
one hand
everyone if it's very raw if you touch
it it just really hurts so if I have a
wound around not being wanted
then
or the belief that I'm not
then decades later if anything reminds
me of that it hurts as much as it did
when I originally incured the wound
so in in one sense trauma is an unhealed
wound that touched we get triggered
that's what triggering means by the way
some old wound gets activated or touched
and the other thing that happens to
wounds is that they scar over and Scar
Tissue has certain characteristics it's
thick
it has no nerve ending so there's no
feeling in it so people traumatize
disconnected from their feelings
um Sky tissue is rigid it's not flexible
so we lose kind of response flexibility
so when something happens we tend to
react in typical stereotypical
predictable
dysfunctional ways because of the
rigidity and Scar Tissue doesn't grow
like healthy flesh so people are
traumatized tend to be stuck in
emotional states that characterized
their development when they were
traumatized so when somebody says to you
don't miss such a baby uh
doesn't sound very pleasant but there's
some truth to it it means that you're
probably reacting according to the lines
of someone that you sustained as an
infant and now you're you're reacting as
if that wound was happening all over
again this is what one of my friends in
the trauma World Peter Levine calls the
attorney of the past
so something happens in the present
and we react
as if we're back there in the past when
this first happened
and we're not in the present moment at
all
and I was I was trying to figure out how
many people
um as a percentage of the population
have a
have trauma but then I I you know I read
this stat with 60 of adults um say that
they've had sort of a traumatic early
upbringing or whatever or traumatic
events from their childhood but then I
thought maybe everybody has trauma
it depends on um how we understand
trauma so if we understand trauma is
only the really terrible things that
happen to people which do happen to
people you know in the book I talked
about a British friend of mine but not
living in Canada
um they are a yoga teacher and a
meditation teacher and a psychologist
and an artist actually and they grew up
in some orphanage here in Britain where
they were racially taunted every every
morning you know words that are in the
book by her permission which I'm not
going to cite here publicly
and that gave her a sense of deficient a
sense of self that I'm just not good
enough that I don't belong and so on
there's those obvious traumas or the
obvious trauma of being sexually abused
so men who are sexually abused according
to Canadian study have tripled the rate
of heart attacks as adults you know and
all kinds of physiological reasons well
that should be the case so there's those
self-evident Lord big tea traumas that
we call Big tea terminal Cat TV the
capital T trauma with the capital T
there's a certain percentage of the
population much larger than we think
subject to that if you include
um All the known factors such as
physical sexual or emotional abuse
spanking by the way has not been shown
to be as traumatic as harsher forms of
physical abuse spanking which is still
recommended by so-called experts who
should be named remain unnamed for the
moment uh the death of a parent the
violence in a Family Violence parental
violence against each other a parent
being jailed
depending mentally ill
did I say apparent being addicted a
rancor's divorce these are the
identified Big traumas Big T traumas no
not to mention poverty
not to mention extreme inequality
war and so on
but then
if you remember that trauma is not what
happens to you but what happens inside
you
this is the wound people can be wounded
not just by bad things happening to them
but small children can be wounded
in loving families
where they don't get their knees met
I mean that's obvious in the physical
sense if a child doesn't get proper
nutrition
their body will suffer their mind will
suffer
we're also creatures with the emotional
needs as important as our physical needs
so when the child's emotional needs are
not met that child is wounded and that's
what we call small tea trauma which is
not the big ticket events such as I
described but just the child's need to
be loved unconditionally to be held when
distressed to be responded to to be seen
to be heard to be allowed their full
range of emotion without them being
stamped on in the name of so-called
discipline
um
the right to play
creatively
spontaneously out there in nature not
with these damn digital the gadgets that
subvert and hijacked the child's
imagination
but spontaneous Play That's essential
for band development
so what I'm saying is that when these
needs are not for the
unconditional loving attachment
relationship when those needs are
frustrated children are also hurt and I
call that trauma as well because it
shows up later in life as the impact of
painful wounds
so drama in this Society for all kinds
of reasons is far more common than we
imagined from sitting here and speaking
to I don't know somewhere over 100
different people that come from all
walks of life but specifically people
that are successful in their Industries
and you talked about you know
how
um an anomalous early upbringing can
create sort of abnormality in an adult a
lot of the people I sit here are
successful because of some kind of
abnormality or at least their
interpretation of some kind of early
event that caused them to have some sort
of abnormal belief about themselves that
they're not enough so they become a
billionaire or a gold medalist or
whatever it might be yeah one of the
things that I thought I could predict is
I thought I could if they told me I
thought after doing 100 episodes if they
told me the traumatic event they'd been
through I could predict the the outcome
in them but there's a disconnect there
because you know I'd sit here with a
guest who went through one of your tall
um capital T traumas like domestic
violence and one of them might become
incredibly angry yeah and one of them
might become the most peaceful loving
person I've ever met yeah and that
taught me that there's this thing in
between the event which is what you call
interpretation yeah and I found that
really I found that as that kind of
makes it really difficult to diagnose
well no look so the two examples you
gave
um
that really peaceful person may be
really peaceful for genuinely good
reasons such as they've found the milk
of human love flowing through their
veins and they've had some spiritual
reconciliation with the world where they
may have lit genuinely learned
compassion for themselves and others but
they could also be very nice and
peaceful because they're suppressing
their healthy anger
because they're actually sitting on
their rage unconsciously which is going
to show up in a form of some kind of
Health manifestation I guarantee you
later on so you can't tell from the
outside
without asking some questions uh or I
can give you the example of a Donald
Trump
who
had a really traumatic childhood I mean
his father was a this as described by
his psychologist niece Mary Trump his
father Trump's father who is Mary's
grandfather
was a psychopath
and who really demeaned and harshly
treated their children
so Trump decides unconsciously
that by the way I'm not talking about
his policies here I'm not this is not a
political debate and in the book I point
out that his opponent was also
traumatized uh Hillary Clinton said this
is this is a uh ecumenical uh view of
trauma and politics and not choosing
sides I'm just saying that you can see
his trauma in every moment he opens his
mouth
his grandiosities need to make himself
bigger more powerful aggressive and eat
as much as said in his autobiography
that the world is a horrible place a
doggy dog place where everybody was
after you everybody wants your wife and
your house and your wealth and this is
your friends
never mind your enemies but that's the
world he lives in though that world that
he lives in reflects his childhood home
he developed that world you
he came to it honestly you might say
because that's the world that he lived
in
and he gets to be really successful in
this crazy world
you know financially although people
question you know was he really as big a
success as he says he was but he
certainly was successful politically if
by success you mean the attainment of
power
his brother on the other hand Mary
Trump's father Trump's niece's father
drag himself to death
and they were both responses to the same
you can never say it's exactly the same
for two kids but there was that there
was a toxic home environment one ends up
dead as an alcoholic
the other ends up at the Pinnacle of
power
um
and when I look at them both
I see dysfunction there significant
dysfunction here
so one of the one of those the
consequences of that early upbringing
was it materialized itself as sort of
addiction
and the other got the same psychological
reinforcement or the thing missing from
power and work and money
Donald Trump learned that the way to
survive is to be aggressive and harsh
and competitive and to get the other
before they get to you
which is a faithful reproduction of his
early childhood experiences so for him
these were not choices so much as
survival
techniques and
uh when they talk about his
lying
well
I don't know when he's lying or when
he's not but my sense is that often he
actually believes what he's saying and
actually he's a biographer or the person
who
co-wrote his
cause the autobiographical the art of
the deal this this writer says that he's
never met anybody who is so capable of
believing something that's not true to
be true if he wants it to be true
now that's the mark of a traumatized
child
you know a denial of reality
it is an inauguration there was a
certain number of people that came today
he couldn't stand it that there weren't
as many people there as came to Barack
Obama's
inauguration they were much smaller
number of people there
he created this reality where many more
people came to his inauguration
now what age behavior is that
that's a four-year-old but more kids
came to his party than my party that
can't be true
but that's Donald's way of dealing with
reality
it's not a moral failing as such that's
how he survived
and these survival
mechanisms for them get to form our
personalities and again in this world
sometimes they pay off
in certain ways
is that is that often the case with
pathological lies they've learned to lie
as a way to survive oh absolutely the
the German philosopher writer Nichi
Friedrich Nietzsche said people lie
their way out of reality who have been
hurt by reality
and so I've lied you know like when I
had my shopping addiction I relied Every
Day to my wife
you know and even afterwards when she
tried when she stopped trying to change
my behavior
I said just tell me
if you're going to show up you're going
to spend another thousand dollars on
music just tell me
I still couldn't
because
I was so ashamed of it and so the lying
became like a
a way of survival for me defense against
reality it's a defense against reality
and is the defense against
um being judged
you know well that says something about
my childhood you know nobody's born a
liar as we say in this book there are
congenial Liars but there are no
congenital Liars no one day old baby
tells any lies no wonder your baby
pretends anything if we end up
pretending in any way at all to the
extent that we do it's because we have
to learn that's what we must do to
survive
you said something at the start when I
gave the example that I have this I sat
with a guest here who went through
domestic abuse yeah and they are the
calmest person and then you said well
maybe they're suppressing it and in fact
the minute you said that it reminded me
of something they said which is they
they said to me on this podcast that
they had
um angry outbursts all the time
so sometimes their child will come up to
them yeah
um and want to play when they're working
and they'll snap yeah and they're trying
to they're trying to deal with that yeah
that's what I meant that they're sitting
on this
um
creator of volcanic crater of anger
which sometimes bursts out of them so
their their demeanor is like a really
developed suppressed
um way of handling rage
which rage when they were children had
they expressed would have got them into
more trouble so suppressing it
repressing it
became their survival it's all about
survival you see so it became their
survival mechanism no
that person as long as they keep it that
way they're
at risk
their risk for mental health diagnosis
like depression
because what what is depression it means
you're pushing something down that's
what it means what to be pushed down
our natural emotions why do we push them
down because we have to to survive so
that that person I don't know I can't
prognosticate what's going to happen to
them but if they don't work it out
in general
they're at risk for some kind of mental
or physical manifestation that's my
experience
quick one some of you may know we've got
a brand new sponsor on this podcast
American Express and you've got a brand
new exclusive offer for a limited time
only which I can't wait to tell you
about from the 18th of October to the
16th of November American Express is
offering new card members a 60 000 Point
membership reward as a welcome bonus
when you join when you spend a minimum
of 8 000 pounds across the first three
months this is simply a thank you for
joining American Express and for those
that don't know you can use your
American Express business platinum card
points in exchange for various rewards
such as booking travel holidays gift
cards and so much more so essentially
you're rewarded with huge prizes for
just using their card to spend on your
usual purchases and I've had a look
through at what sixty thousand points
can get you so if you'd like to find out
how you can get your hands on your new
American Express business card then
search American Express business
platinum card to find out more
a quick one from our longest standing
sponsor hero I I can't tell you over the
last I'd say over the last really it's
been about two and a half years it was
really um post pandemic how much my
health has become such a huge priority
in my life huel has been probably the
most important partner in my health
Journey because
I've been in the boardrooms I've been to
their offices
tens and tens and tens and tens of times
I've seen how they make their decisions
on nutrition and that's why it's such a
wonderful thing to be able to talk to
this audience about a brand and a
product that is so unbelievably linked
to my values and the place I am in my
life are valuing the gym exercise
movement my mind my breathing and all of
those things and most importantly my
nutrition that is the role he all plays
and so every time I get to read these
ads out I do it with such passion
because I really really believe every
word I'm saying and I absolutely love
the brand so if you haven't already
tried Hill and you've been resistant to
my my pestering then give it a go and
let me know how you get on talked about
expressing one's emotions and something
you've talked about in this book but
also previously is this idea that there
is such a thing as healthy anger yeah um
it's one of the seven A's of your of
healing as you say the first being the
topic a topic we've talked about already
which is acceptance yeah
um the next being awareness well
awareness I wish we had put into this
book but we didn't not into this book uh
in this book I booked Four A's and uh I
left that awareness and that was an
Omission on my part really yeah it was
I'm sorry but it was so in the book you
have authenticity
anger acceptance
an agency yeah and yeah acceptance yeah
so awareness you've said before before
this book that awareness is the starting
point yeah
I found that to be so true in my life
but it's not very easy I feel like
awareness is a is a luxury or a
privilege that is very hard fought yeah
because you're guessing yeah you're
guessing based on pattern recognition so
I was guessing 25 years old I can't get
into relationship any time a girl comes
near me yeah even if I've pursued her I
run off and to figure out why I was
doing that to even identify the behavior
pattern and go that's not helpful that's
not going to lead me to feeling whole
yeah
um where does that come from took 25
years and a lot of like introspection
but but most people they're living
unaware of the puppet master of trauma
that is driving their life that's a
really good analogy the trauma really is
like um a puppet master behind the
scenes in the unconscious pulling your
strings and you're not aware of it you
know do you remember Pinocchio yeah so
remember what Pinocchio says at the end
the way when he finally becomes a real
boy yeah yeah he says how foolish I was
when I was a puppet
and to the extent that we're being
activated by these
unconscious strings that are traumas
pulling behind the scenes
and reacting in our lives and we think
we're autonomous free beings but we're
actually being controlled by something
in the past that we haven't worked out
we're puppets
reality puppets
there's not there's not much freedom in
that there's no there's no freedom in it
at all
so I mean I suppose the opposite of
trauma if you want to revisit that
question is is liberation
interesting
Liberation and by reconnection by
reconnection of Liberation from the from
the inexorable power of the unconscious
which is like cutting the strings in a
way kind of brings me to there's kind of
two ways to I want to go with that but
the first question I have about about
trauma and the puppet master analogy is
do we ever do we ever really cut the
strings or do we just kind of learn to
pull against them when they try and tell
us to do something with more Force then
they're exerting in the opposite
direction
um
that doesn't work very well
pushing against it because they're still
reactive you're still not in charge
you're just in automatic resistance mode
to something there's no freedom in that
either
you know so yeah
um
but awareness that you mentioned is huge
because weren't you aware that there's
this see the thing about these strings
may not Fray right away
but once you wear that ah
this reaction of mine
it's not about what's going on right now
there's something old being activated
here that awareness alone weakens the it
slackens the strings a bit no you know
they no longer is taught they're no
longer is automatically
um
capable of pulling on you
so it does have to be begin with
awareness of them ultimately
if we realize that this Puppet Master is
just a desperate little person trying to
get you to survive the only way he she
they knew how when you were small when
they were small if you make friends with
it
but we believe it of its duties
saying thanks very much but I can handle
it now
it eventually Becomes Her friend rather
than sort of our
Master you know
you know on that first step of just
acknowledging just understanding that
there is a puppet master they're
controlling us and exactly which strings
that Puppet Master is is pulling in our
lives how does one go about
awareness the process of awareness is
that I mean is it introspection keeping
a diary therapy what is it well all that
I mean it all or any but even when you
ask how you go about it
what is the it well for you to say how
to go about it you already must have
some degree of awareness if you didn't
you wouldn't even be asking the question
so that's the very first step
of realizing that there's something here
to work on there's something here to
work through it does not need to be the
way it is that already is the biggest
step the Buddha said that that to
recognize the source of your suffering
is the first step towards relieving the
suffering and so as soon as you ask how
you go about it you've already taken a
huge step because a lot of people don't
even know that there's an it
they just think this is a reality that
this is life so we're realizing that
this it doesn't have to be the way it is
that's already a huge step now beyond
that
yoga meditation
um
nature
um therapy of all kinds Bodywork
of all kinds like like somatic
experiencing or um or um
cranial sacral treatments or even
massage therapy it's incredible what can
be revealed just through body work like
that then all kinds of forms of therapy
the ones I teach the ones other people
teach
journaling
um certain exercises in this book that
we recommend like just ask yourself will
you have trouble saying no in life to
things you don't really want to do and
working that through on a regular basis
so there's lots of ways once you open
the door
you know
I have a chapter on psychedelics here
which is a
again it's not like a Panacea or for
everyone but surely it's a helpful
modality for a lot of people
so um some people may actually benefit
from taking pharmaceutical medications
if their situation is dire enough
but not as the final answer but as a way
of getting respite that allowed them to
go to work on the real issues that cause
them to be depressed or
anxious or tuning out you know so any
and all of these things other people
don't even want to open those doors
though because they there's so much pain
associated with maybe going back or
revisiting an early experience that they
just think it's better keep the doors
shut yeah
um and get get to tomorrow that's true
um to which I have two answers one is
it's true it's painful
um because all the pain you didn't want
to feel and you've been running away
from through your compensatory behaviors
like like your addictions are nothing
but an attempt to escape from Pain
that's all they are that's not you know
they're not a disease they're not a
genetic whatever it is addictions are
very simply an attempt to escape pain
which could create more pain
but that's what they are
and so we get addicted to work to sex to
pornography the gambling to the internet
to shopping to eating to power on that
point I find it so fast that you that
when you mentioned in your previous book
that you know you classify things like
food yeah social media yeah shopping
yeah porn and work as types of addiction
that was uh that in and of itself was a
bit of a revelation for me because I
never saw work as an addiction the
minute you said it was and I kind of
link it to
you know heroin addiction which is
providing a you know a certain
psychological physiological
um benefit to me yeah temporarily
temporarily yeah of course it's a
[ __ ] addiction of course work is an
addiction because they have that
addiction well it can be an addiction
yeah or it can also be sacred it can
also be fulfilling in the manifestation
of your creative urges but it's so it's
not the
but it's strange to say not that I
recommend it but it's possible even to
use heroin in a non-addictive way
I don't personally get it and I would
never want to but the addiction is never
in the
Behavior itself it's in your
relationship to the behavior so if the
particular activity gives you temporary
relief or pleasure and therefore you
crave it
but it causes harm in the long term and
you can't give it up you've got an
addiction and I don't care what the
activity is could be drugs and all the
other things that we mentioned and and
and it employs the same brain Circus by
the way the workaholic is after the same
brain chemical that the cocaine addict
is after dopamine
you know and people can be even addicted
to their own stress hormones like
adrenaline the so-called Adrenaline
Junkies there's such a thing you know so
almost anything can be addictive if it
serves the purpose of temporarily easing
some distress but causing harm in the
long term is is escapism the right word
to use then for it if we're
because it it doesn't sound as much like
we're escaping rather than we are
seeking something I'm seeking relief
from a certain mental state like like
I just gave you a definition of
addiction so I think I don't know what
addictions you've had what happened or
haven't besides you know but what did
that do for you
temporarily
um and give you something made me feel
like I was valid and I was pursuing a
sense of accomplishment and validation
and a good sense of worth worth yeah it
was worthy yeah no is that something
that people need or not
yes yeah that's a good thing but the
real question is
why did you ever get the idea that you
didn't have the words why did I get the
I didn't have the word that's what
trauma comes because I was called the
n-word when I was yeah eight by a kid in
school exactly and then I know myself
because your mother screamed at your
father yeah yeah you know and and so all
that together and so
and that's emotionally painful like
what's it feel like to be not to have a
sense of word that's painful and so
that's why my Mantra is don't ask why
the addiction that's why the pain
and if you understand why the pain you
have to look at that person's life
and what the benefit of the addiction is
that's something that you say in the
previous book that I found is it's a
flipping of narrative where you say we
should be asking what the benefit of the
addiction is well and like in your case
yeah it gives me a sense of worth well
okay
I'll say to you if you come to me
because you say like I'm broke or like
it's causing some harm in my life it's
keeping keeping me from Intimate
Relationships that makes me stressed and
tired whatever it is
that's the first thing I would ask you
for you of you is what is it doing for
you and you say a sense of word and I'd
say you know what
you deserve to have a sense of birth I
totally understand why you'd want to
engage in an activity that gives it to
you
but given that it's causing you harm
let's look at why you don't have a sense
of worth and how else you might develop
it that isn't harmful to you you know so
but you you start with what's right
about it what are you looking for and
what you're looking for is always valid
and how one would go about how would one
go about getting that sense of worth and
asking for a friend
well um that would be a matter of
um some form of work people who meditate
often deal with that issue through the
meditation not always
certainly therapy
you know
um
by recognizing also that what you're
doing to get a sense of where it doesn't
really do it for you just by getting
honest about it you know
so there's all kinds of ways but the
first step is the recognition
that's the first step that you say is uh
missing missing from the book which is
that sort of awareness the next thing
which I've been it's been really front
of mind in my life recently because I've
been asked this a few times on stage and
I've been trying to find the words to
really
um articulate the importance of it is
and this is one of your forays in this
book about how to heal is authenticity
yeah really interesting concept because
I've been trying to articulate why the
fact that I've just shared all this
stuff with you yeah and the fact that I
do this every week yeah I'm getting
closer and closer to that sort of
authentic self where there's really the
mask is kind of dropping on me why
that's been so healing for me why is
authenticity such a good way an
important way for us to heal
it's much more than the way for us to
heal it's actually who we are like what
you're actually asking is why is it
important for a creature to be true to
its own nature
because
that's what we're meant to do we're
meant to be here as ourselves
you know and and and when we nod
ourselves because we had to abandon
ourselves or
betray ourselves disconnect from
ourselves in order to survive
um
we lost connections with our essence and
uh
I mean how does it feel
to
be a successful CEO and you know more
than realizing your Financial dreams
but to be a workaholic and and and and
not to be available to yourself in areas
of your life that really matter to you
as opposed to
being honest about your stuff
sharing with other people uh dropping
the veil dropping the I mean
to answer your question what does it
feel like I mean can you sense the
difference in your body feels lighter
well yeah expansive exactly well that's
the answer yeah that's why it's so
important
so many of us so many of us um
live in authentic lives because as you
said it's it's because either
because from an early age we were
escaping
um some kind of you know reality in
order to help us to survive or then the
other thing that happens a bit later on
in life is we develop an identity which
becomes a career which becomes a Social
Circle which becomes a prison
of um our inauthentic selves we get
trapped in there you know because I was
good at something or because I you know
I felt accepted in this job as a lawyer
so I am now living inauthentically as
this robot in this prison
um
and it's a it's a
there's often a real perception of risk
and loss in danger
of trying to get out of that prison and
trying to get close to our authentic
selves we feel like we'll lose our
friendship Circle we'll feel like we'll
we'll let our parents down he wanted us
to become a lawyer you know all of these
things
I guess you see that a lot in your in
your work well there is that risk and
but here's the issue as a child you had
no choice
but to go for
acceptance and being approved of and
being received
um under any under any conditions no
matter what you had to give up of your
authenticity you had to give up your
authenticity you had no choice in the
matter
at a certain point as adults we get we
learn that this lack of authenticity
this this connection from ourselves this
separation from our gut feelings
um is costing us it's costing us in
terms of our physical health our our
Peace of Mind our relationship our
mental health and so on
you'll never be as vulnerable again as
you were as when you were a child you
never be as helpless as dependent as
um resourceless
no it's true that if you develop the
whole set of relationships based on your
authentic inauthentic Persona some
people
in your life may not like it if you
gradually move towards authenticity they
may not like it it's not what they
wanted from you you're going to find out
who your friends are
you're really gonna fight because your
real friends will say oh I'm so happy
for you
we were waiting for this other fans will
say uh that's not what I signed up for
you know
the question is you still have to decide
as an infant as a young child I had no
agency
in the choice of you know authenticity
and attachment no I do
which one do you want to go with what is
the cost of being an authentic I can't
make that decision for anybody else
nobody can make that decision for
anybody else but most people will find
that choosing authenticity as benefits
Way Beyond whatever they might lose
that's what I find
and you said the word their agency which
is the second of the Four A's yeah on
how to heal now agency when when I read
that word I I hear like personal
responsibility taking personal
responsibility yeah over my life exactly
which also means not letting you know
you don't use try you don't wear trauma
as a badge you know or you don't use it
as a get out of jail pass in a game of
Monopoly oh I was traumatized so I can't
I can't be any other way you know I mean
giving all the power to the Puppet
Master yeah yeah exactly
so agency means actually I take the
responsibility not for what happened to
me
not even how I interpreted the world as
a result going backwards but how I
interpret the world from now on do I
still want to interpret the world and my
role in it based on some decision I made
when I was a one-year-old that's where
agency comes in agency also means that
if I have
any kind of dysfunction or illness it's
not just that I put my hands in the
hands of a put my my faith in the hands
of a physician or a Healer but I I have
I make the decisions I listen to your
advice I accept some I don't accept some
but I'm the one who's making the
decisions along with what seems right to
me
to agency
first thing in your in your work
throughout your work you use
alliteration as a lot as a way to kind
of summarize and make ideas really
memorable
it really helps it's an old trick it's a
trick it's a writing trick right well it
also works you know before ways or uh
before almost but I don't I don't know
what to say you know what I'm I'm
denigrating my work if I say it's a
trick no it's just something just the
way things occur to me that's all it is
one of the one of the um alliteration
devices you use is also relates to
limiting beliefs and how we can undo
self-limiting beliefs with the five R's
yeah relabel reattribute refocus re re
value and recreate yeah now from what I
understood of those relabeling is
the story and the belief that is
limiting to us
um well it taste something like um
eurocologist yeah I need to go to work I
need to do this work really building as
I don't need to do this work I just have
a belief that I need to do this work
okay so that real building just takes a
degree of separation from the
behavior and and actually it's true it's
not that you need to do all the circuits
you have this belief so the relay
building just says it for what it is by
the way I have to acknowledge that I
these these five R's only one in his
mind I stole the other four from a
psychiatrist just I I mentioned that in
the book but I find it very helpful
technique but the it was developed for
people with obsessively compulsive
Tendencies so the relabel is not that I
have to wash my hands 100 times I just
have a belief that I have to wash my
hand a lot of times that's the context
in which it was developed I think it
works for all kinds of all kinds of
Dynamics and then if I and then so I've
re-labeled it
I don't have to work to feel a sense of
validation but I have a belief that I do
that's right and then I reattribute it
which is the second R which means I get
clear on where it's come from yeah so
let's say you have to believe that
you're not worth it it's not too then
I'm not worth it I just never believed
that I'm not worth it
okay or it may not be too then I'm not
worth it but I do have a belief that I'm
not worth it re-um attribute means this
is an old brain circuit sending me an
old message it's got nothing to do with
reality it has to do with some
experience that I had a long time ago
that's to be attribute you just say
where is it actually coming from there's
a circuit in your brain that's wired
with the message
you're not worth it and it's going to
keep repeating that message well you say
okay that's where it's coming from until
I refocus which is the photo yeah so
refocus is just to give yourself some
space so if you ever say uh I need to go
to work uh okay refocus means well for
five minutes
maybe in five minutes I'll go to work
but five minutes I won't I'm gonna put
on some piece of music or go for a walk
or meditate or whatever so you refocus
you put the attention somewhere else
right just just so that to prove to
yourself but you actually have some
agency over your brain
if only for five minutes if you have
this belief that I'm not worth it
well you can go back to it in five
minutes if you want just for five
minutes though consider all the ways
they've made a contribution
consider all the ways that people have
acknowledged your
benign the presence in their lives
the times that people uh have told you
that they've loved you or that you told
somebody else just for five minutes hang
up with that five minutes later you want
to go back to this belief that or if you
can't help going back to this belief
that you know I said well that's okay
but at least create some space it's all
about creating space between yourself
and these beliefs or these behaviors
and in that five minutes you're
basically accepting new evidence to be
true or you're proving that other
evidence is true I didn't need to go and
work well you're also proving that you
don't have to spend all your time
subjected to those beliefs you can take
a Hiatus from it
at least for a while and they are not
you they're not you yeah and then
revalue
um
reevalue it really what it should mean
or maybe more accurately devalue because
you say what has been the actual value
this belief that I'm not worth it what
has been the actual value of it in my
life or this tendency of mine to be a
workaholic what has been actual value
it made me tired it made me alienated or
it keeps me depressed so it keeps me
hopelessly trying to prove something
which I can never prove to myself anyway
to external activity so that you
actually look at what does it mean it's
actually impact on your life
what has been his real value
um sometimes the value is positive
though right like I think about my own
workaholic workaholism if that's the
term I think uh there's some there's
some positives here yeah a lot of
negatives yeah well it is the positive
do the workaholism or is it due to your
capacity to work hard and and on behalf
of a goal they're not the same
new capacity to work hard to achieve a
certain goal is simply a gift that you
have
and something that maybe takes some
discipline an application on your part
that's not working that's just
a strong positive work ethic
the recallism and you're driven to work
you actually don't need to
it's funny because it reminds me of an
analogy I've been talking about in the
last couple of episodes of this podcast
of the the distinction between being
driven and being dragged yeah it's like
am I which side of the Lorry am I flying
down the motorway am I tied to the front
and am I running and pulling the Lorry
or am I just like my ankles attached to
the back of the Lorry as it flies down
the motorway because I'm being dragged
but if I may I would say that neither of
those are particularly desirable
but but but but it's the distinction
that I made before between being driven
and being called yeah because if you
called it's if I call you
say Stephen would you come and have
dinner with me you can say yes you can
say no I just gave you a call and you
could say literally I'm talking about
calling you know telephone call you know
you can say yes you can say no it's a
decision now but you're the one who's
making the decision yeah when you're
dragged or pushed or pulled you're not
making the decision I'm a slave to the
decision to that that's right to the
activity
one of the um one of the really
interesting things I wanted to talk to
you about is is ADHD yeah
um I've had a few of my friends and my
close Friendship Circle diagnosed with
ADHD recently
um and then I looked into some of the
statistics around ADHD and I found this
statistic that said in the 1980s one in
20 U.S children were diagnosed with ADHD
today the number is roughly one in nine
yeah
um
and just generally you know around me
there's it feels like and this could
just be because of my own little narrow
Circle or it could be because of a wider
thing happening in society it feels like
there's been an increase in diagnosis of
mental illness and things like ADHD and
the causes when I spoke to my friend
about what he believed the cause of um
his ADHD was and he's posted this on
LinkedIn and talks about it very
publicly now
um it seemed to point to he seemed to
believe it was relating to
some kind of genetic or heritable
um Factor now the issue the issue that
I've sort of been contending with myself
and why I spoke to Johann Hari about
this and others about this is
if I if I am to accept that then I am I
feel like I'm accepting that we're being
born somewhat broken and this is almost
what Johann Hari talked about in in the
early stages of his teenage years where
he he was made to believe that there was
this chemical imbalance in his brain and
therefore he was born broken and here's
the medication to solve it yeah
so but I don't want I don't believe that
I don't I don't personally believe that
we're we're born broken well um and
anybody interested in the subject
my daughter I think Joanne and actually
this is to read my book and it is called
scattered minds and um I was diagnosed
within my 50s and so were a couple of my
kids but but I never bought into the
idea this is a genetic disease or that
it's a disease at all genetic or
otherwise
um now as for the rising number of
um people being diagnosed with it there
could be two reasons at least one is
we're better diagnosis so before we
wouldn't have noticed it but now we are
or genuinely there's more people who are
having trouble in certain ways such as
with attention and impulse control and
so on
but either way the fact is that many
more children are being diagnosed and
medicated
for this condition particularly in the
U.S but also increasingly uh here in the
UK as well and in China and elsewhere
now
um as I said earlier if we the fact is
here's the actual reality nobody's ever
found the gene for ADHD nobody's ever
found the gene that says if you have
this Gene you're gonna have ADHD no such
thing has ever been found no group of
genes ever been found that says if you
can have this Gene you're gonna have
this condition nor ever will be and no
such gene or group of genes have ever
been found that if you don't have these
genes you will not have the condition
now there are some diseases there are
genetic one runs in my family muscular
dystrophy if you have the gene you're
going to have the disease my mother had
it my aunt had it
that's a genetic condition and if you
have the gene you'll have the disease
very rare those kind of diseases
no there are some genes that the more
them you have
the more likely you are to have any
number of mental health diagnoses ADHD
depression anxiety even psychosis
bipolar Illness but there's no group of
genes or set of genes or Gene that
themselves determine any one condition
as a matter of fact you can have those
same genes and not have any condition
whatsoever
so something is being passed on but it's
not any kind of condition that's being
passed on what's being passed on is
sensitivity and the more sensitive you
are the more you're gonna feel whatever
is going on in the environment so you
take the same sensitive kid with these
genes that confer greater sensitivity of
them and sensitive means to feel from
the Latin word to feel sincere the more
sensitive you are the more you're going
to feel the more you feel the more bad
stuff happens the more pain you're going
to be in and the more compensating
you're gonna have to do
the same time with those same genes if
you tweeted well and you grow up in a
healthy environment you just be creative
and happy and joyful and a leader and an
artist or a shaman or or a very creative
CEO or whatever you're going to be so
the genes don't determine they make you
more sensitive to their environment no
if you go back to what I said about the
tuning out it's simply a defense
so the more sensitive you are
and the stress in the environment the
more you're going to feel the stress the
more you're gonna need to escape from it
by tuning out
so he didn't inherit ADHD you inherited
a sensitivity that makes it more likely
under stressful circumstances that you
revert to tuning out when your brain is
developing which by the way is an organ
that develops physiologically under the
impact of the emotional environment
so if there's a lot of stress in a
child's life and what I'm saying is in
this Society is that more and more
parents are stressed not because they
don't love their kids not because
they're not doing their way utmost to
provide for them but because they're
more stressed to all kinds of social
political economic reasons I mean if you
look at inflation in Britain is a high
risk right now more people are going to
be stressed financially
Financial stress on the parents
translates into physiological stress in
the children
those children may want to tune out
because it's too much to be in their
present some of them will be diagnosed
with ADHD
they didn't inherit anything in terms of
a disease they're just reacting to the
environment
so if we're diagnosing more and more
kids these days I think it's because the
parenting environment has been much more
stressed and that's backed up in this
book where you mentioned that study of
65 000 parents yeah um and their
children with ADHD right
you say well there's more trauma in
their lives yeah so the children they do
a study with 65 000. I forget
I read it yeah yeah
but many thousands of kids yeah so
because I found that to be really really
sort of um supportive of what you just
said where I I'm again I'm I'm saying
this from memory but a study of 65 000
um children and their parents and they
found that those parents who had more
adverse
um traumatic events in their lives ended
up having having a higher chance of
having a child that had ADHD well look
if you look at um the United States at
least
poor kids and kids of so-called color
are much more like to be diagnosed with
ADHD interesting no why would that be
the case because they're living with so
much more stress
men as well right men as well adults you
mean men yeah so I read that more men
more boys more men are diagnosed partly
because in men the the symptom of
hyperactivity seems to be there more
often so when a kid is sitting in school
and the cancer still that's obvious the
teacher will notice it the girl who's
kind of dreamy and tunes out
kind of Fades away at the back of the
class she doesn't create any problems
so they don't then that's one of the
reasons but also
um
funny to say but young boys infant boys
are more sensitive to a mental
environmental pressure than girls are
for some strange reason so they're more
likely to be affected by these factors
Singapore like that in the class that's
a fidgety that has a poor attention span
bad response to stress we medicate what
is the impact of that approach to
treatment medicating super early
I used to
when I worked as a physician I would
certainly prescribe medication sometimes
it's a question of who's prescribing it
and what intention
if I understand that the real problem in
this child is not that there's anything
intrinsically wrong with the child
but that they were developed in a
stressed environment and those stresses
are still acting on them
and one of the stresses is that parents
don't understand the kids behaviors and
they tend to react rather harshly
then if I change if I can help the
parent understand the sensitive nature
of their child
which also means that when positive
changes occur in the environment the kid
will be very responsive to that as well
if the parents can create a positive
accepting understanding atmosphere in
the home and work on their own stresses
so they don't unconsciously pass them on
to the kids that kid will change very
quickly
and I say well if in the short term the
child wants the medication to function
better and no child should be forced to
take medication and medication are never
the final answer at the very most their
stop cap there's no proof whatsoever
that medications help anybody heal from
ADHD they simply suppress symptoms which
may be helpful in the short term but for
God's sakes go to work on the long-term
development of that child and what does
that mean create the conditions image
healthy development takes place that
child will do very very well if you
think the problem is a disease they're
just going to medicate away the symptoms
of
what about fat adults they might I'm
thinking of my friend that he's he's in
his 30s and he got the diagnosis of ADHD
in his 30s yeah he's been given this
medication which he presumably has to
take for Life he's told me the
medication has helped helped him Focus
this helps him Focus has helped him
Focus yeah it's been a game changer
Steve you know yeah yeah I I've taken
medication myself for ADHD and it helped
me focus it helped me write my first
book
um I didn't dig it for this one as a
matter of fact more recently when I was
beginning to write the medication I
thought maybe I would take a bit of
stimulant like I used to and just to see
if it helps me write the book better all
it did all it did is give me side
effects my brain has changed I don't
need it anymore you know so I I would
say to your friend if the medication is
helping right now and it's not causing
you side effects
I got nothing against it and
you might want to give it a break every
you know every weekend if you don't you
know you might want to use it for when
you're having to work or having to you
know they concentrate but it's up to you
if it helps you function take it but go
to work on the traumas and stresses that
are driving the ADHD going back to your
childhood
and you know I may say my book in ADHD
scattered Minds does outline some ways
to do that
um you might find that you don't need
the medication uh so much anymore or not
at all perhaps number one number two
even if you do your life will be so much
Fuller and so much more um less stressed
if you deal with the underlying factors
then if you simply medicate the symptom
is there I always think in life there's
a cost for all these things we use to
medicate and stimulate ourselves and
yeah so I always always ask myself like
there's got to be it's gonna say there's
got to be a catch here and even for
coffee I'm like what's the catch it
can't just be all up and positive and
with with my friend when he said when he
had the conversation with me about being
on this this medication for life my
first thought is like okay what's the
cost it's going to make you really
focused and better at work but what is
the what is the long-term cost of
I had to talk to your friend friend
those are good questions to ask
when I took medication it made me a much
more efficient workaholic you know it
did nothing for my recallism just made
me much better at it because I could
stay up later now and I was more focused
I get even more things done you know so
um you got to deal with these other
issues did you I did did I deal with
them yes I have and there's so much more
like like dealing with the trauma like
I'm telling you if your friends got ADHD
I can tell you heated stressed early for
years and his parent was her parents
were strapped his pants were stressed so
deal with that deal with what conditions
are you creating now in your life that
create more stress for you
are you taking care of your body are you
exercising are you eating well do you
get out there in nature nature is a
certain kind of Harmony to it which
actually calms the mind you know so are
you doing all these things if you're not
all you're doing is medicating a symptom
if you are taking the medication
specifically to help you focus but
you're working on his other issues
you have a much full life and you may
find you don't need the medication after
all you you came off the medication for
your add yeah
um because I'm a
because I'm just not that medically well
versed what's the difference between AD
ADD and ADHD it's you know it's a kind
of a confusion it is just simply means
that the hyperactivity is present okay
so you can have ADD with or without
hyperactivity okay so the actual you
know proper way to divide it is a d
and in Brackets HD so that in indicating
that the hyperactivity may or may not be
there got you so you you you were on
medication you did the work you know not
on medication yeah
um do you still have the symptoms of ADD
to a certain degree but not in the way
that anyway Bloods my life like one
thing I completely be sure that when I
go on a speaker I'm going to lose
something I'm going to lose my
my portable electrical
tooth cleaner where I'm gonna in this
case I left my rain jacket in Budapest
when I came here and I I you can take it
for granted that my attention will just
not notice something that I haven't
packed yet that's okay I'm going back to
Budapest next week so I get to get my
rain jacket back but sometimes it's the
cost of being me so what you know so no
not in every way
but that's not the point nobody's life
has to be perfect it just has to be a
life that I I want to live and I can
enjoy living
that I have you know so who cares if
sometimes I forget something or I lose
something or even if I'm listening to a
symphony and I can't keep my attention
on it okay so I can't
this you talk about there's some toxic
Society yeah
do you think society's getting more
toxic and if so why what measure shall
we use you know if you use the measure
of a number of kids being medicated
a number of adults having chronic
illness autoimmune disease a number of
students University students
being depressed contemplating suicide
number of children in the United States
killing themselves
um
the number of people on medications of
all kinds
the degree of safety that people have in
society the the rancor or peace that
characterizes political discourse in
this world the
intolerable fact that eight people in
the world I think own as much as the
bottom half
as the bottom 3.5 billion
you know if I look at all those things
by those measures if you look at what's
happening to the environment
if I look at the fact that the people
who are the worst polluters in the
environment also happen to be the most
successful people you know by a certain
measure of success
um
by any number of parameters if I look at
um
oh
racism still affects the lives of so
many people
um and and not just affected in an
emotional sense but actually
physiologically you know
it's a this is a toxic society and those
measures are getting worse they're not
getting better and inequality is getting
worse here in the UK and elsewhere
so yeah I think it's getting more toxic
what's the antidote well
um how about we go back to this word
awareness like like people just have to
get that this is how it is and in the
last chapter I don't lay out a political
program you know I don't see that as my
role to do that I have my own political
ideas and preferences but I don't want
to impose them on the reader but I do
say
first of all we have to lose our
illusions
that this is that this normality is
actually healthy or natural we have to
just get
cognizant that what we consider to be
normal is actually bad for us
um number one number two
um
just if we introduced the concept of
trauma into Health Care
like the average doctor again strange to
say doesn't hear a single lecture in
their medical training about the impact
of trauma on physical or mental health
which is astonishing given that it was a
British psychologist Dr Richard benthal
who pointed out not that many years ago
that the evidence linking what we call
mental illness and childhood adversity
is about as strong as the evidence
linking smoking and lung cancer
and the average physician doesn't hear a
word about that it's astonishing
education teachers if they understood
Child Development brain development the
developmental factors that I that
children need that I
cite in this book and if they understood
how trauma affects his capacity to learn
to pay attention
and to behave in functional ways The
Daily Telegraph
here in London not that long ago was
bemoaning the fact that kids aren't
caned anymore in schools
I mean they were but they were but they
were moaning about is that we no longer
traumatized kids quite as harshly as we
used to
that's what it that's all it does caning
so if teachers understood that the
behaviors on the part of children are
actually manifestations of emotional
dynamics of frustration and needs not
being met and and very often of trauma
that would change the educational system
if the legal system understood it
that that most people facing the
criminal justice system are actually
traumatized people they could actually
be rehabilitated uh and and and healed
if we understood that instead of just
exposing them to harsh punishments we
actually treated them like human beings
who may have done things that are
unacceptable but that came from traumas
they couldn't have helped and that they
can be helped back to
um healthy functioning as we know from
lots of experience just that little
trauma information would change society
so that's what I can offer as a
physician what about parents what do
they need to know yeah well if parents
actually understood first of all
that the first three years are
everything that if if they get the
template right in the first three years
they can hardly set a foot wrong
afterwards
but in the other hand if we're not
present for our kids emotionally if we
don't understand them if we don't see
them
if we don't
attune to their emotional states we're
going to hurt them
and if they understood what the needs of
children are when I mentioned some of
them for play for
experience of all emotions for
unconditional loving attachment for the
child being able to rest from having to
work to make the relationship work
so the child doesn't have to be good or
nice or beautiful or or or or successful
or they just have to be
approval and acceptance on them if
parents just understood that
and if they understood how important it
is that they take care of their own
emotional needs so that a child doesn't
have to take responsibility
like perhaps you did for the parent
stresses
your parents understood all that and if
Society actually understood her
importance parenting was and it
supported parents who needed the support
to be there for their kids
it wouldn't be financially
costly it would save us a lot of money
not to mention we live a lot more
happier kids
who don't need to be on medications so
yeah and lastly schools schools well
again like I said about Educators if
Educators well here's the thing if you
look at how does the human brain develop
I quite an article I quote an article
from the Harvard Center on the
developing child that appeared in a
journal of Pediatrics official Journal
of the American Pediatric Academy in
2012 February
the article said that the human being
developed it to do a complex process
that begins before birth and continues
into adulthood okay now that means a we
take care of the emotional needs of
pregnant women
number one number two if it conditions
into adulthood continues into adulthood
then the job of the schools if they
understand it right is not to teach kids
what year
the ball of the battle of Australis took
place or the ball of Battle of Waterloo
um or or you know algebra any of any of
that stuff the most important job of the
schools is to promote healthy brain
development
with a child who's with healthy brain
development will actually be naturally
curious they'll want to know about
history that we came to uh to absorb the
skills of algebra they'll want to know
how to use a computer and they'll want
to know
um how to write properly a kid will want
to do that spontaneously because Mastery
and and learning these are human hungers
the human needs
so
in other words the most important job of
the schools is not to cram the kids full
of information
but to help them develop healthy brains
what does that require
safety above all lack of pressure
healthy relationship with nurturing
adults
and if the kids are not going to spend
their time with the adult but they with
the parents which they can't in this
Society like they used to through a
human evolution let them spend their
time with adults who are emotionally
nurturing and emotionally penetrating
the attentive to the child's needs now
you're going to have schools that are
going to really kids teach kids
something and where kids will want to
learn and it's very simple
it doesn't take more training and it
doesn't take more well they take some
training perhaps but not more than what
teachers are getting now so that's sort
of a take in education
I was thinking there about the
importance of doing
certain psychological tests on certain
teachers because if they are also
passing on a generational cycle yeah of
their own at a time when my brain is
still being developed they can have a
huge impact positively or negatively on
my absolutely on my life in the same way
that my parents could absolutely uh it's
quite remarkable teachers don't know how
much power they have because of the
vulnerability of the young brain
and well-meaning teachers
it will sometimes behave in ways that
are really hurtful to kids just because
they don't get it not because they don't
mean well so I've had many adults sit in
my office
say with tears in their eyes about
something a teacher said to them three
decades before
like the classroom
the class will continue and Johnny comes
back to Earth
this kind of sarcastic little dig
can under my child's dignity and sense
of self so easily so if teachers just
understood how powerful they are and how
important they are in helping to promote
healthy brain development
I think the profession would take in a
whole new meaning that would be much
more satisfying than it is right now
it's not the fault of individual
teachers we're talking about a system
that isn't that is toxic
okay but we have closing tradition on
this podcast oh okay where the previous
guest asks a question
for the next guest I didn't get to see
it until I opened the book so there's a
question written here for you before I
ask you this question I did have a
question of my own which was you know
you're in your 70s now
um
what are you still working on in terms
of your own traumas is there anything
even though you're you're in a later
stage of your own life that you you're
still sort of struggling with as it
relates to that Puppet Master pulling on
the strings and
that kind of analogy that we gave
earlier
yeah
um it's
a sense of peace
when I'm not doing anything
just being
the capacity just to be
um that's something I'm
still looking for not well not looking
for like I was looking for a lost puppy
but
I'm still searching myself for
and where exactly does that come from in
your own diagnosis
oh what if I tell you when I find out
I mean I can give you a textbook answer
but it wouldn't be authentic okay
so you don't know
entirely I have some senses I have some
ideas and then
um
it
foreign
it really means
being okay with my mind the way it is
and not needing it to be any different
that's what it would mean
which means if I'm sitting there
for five minutes I don't know how to
reach for the cell phone to occupy my
mind
and now in the midst of this busy book
tour and all the speaking I do I don't I
don't do enough to to take care of that
quiet
little voice inside myself I don't
I think it would take some attention
I can't either though I can't sit for
two I can five minutes I couldn't sit
for five seconds without grabbing my
phone that's weird I noticed the other
day that I was like going to the toilet
and I had no intention of using my phone
in the toilet yeah but I went to get my
phone because you can't be alone with
yourself yeah I can't be alone with
myself yeah I can't
sitting for 30 seconds you know my brain
is that is that because they've built
these algorithms to to stimulate my
dopamine or is it because there's
something in me I guess it goes back to
a point about addiction well it's both I
mean they're they're certainly creative
algorithms to stimulate your brain and
get you hooked on that dopamine head
you're sure if we should they call that
neural marketing neural marketing can
you get that yeah they work on your
brain to get you know to get you
addicted but it also comes from an
earlier discomfort with the self that
predates
any cell phone use it goes back to
earliest childhood where it couldn't
have been comfortable to be
just with yourself because of
circumstances
interesting interesting yeah my because
I've Got Friends that don't have the
same the same addiction with their cell
phones that I do they they can take it
or leave it they put it outside their
bedroom when they go to bed charging in
the kitchen I'm like how I have to hold
mine like my pillow yeah exactly well
like your little safety pillow and
what's the first thing you do when you
wake up in the morning I grab it with
one eye open and all that gunk in my eye
I'm like trying to just you know yeah
yeah we'll have if both you and I work
are not doing that so much okay I'll
give you my number you'll let man we
should we shouldn't discuss by phone how
we're getting on with this that's just
another reason to use my phone but next
time I speak to you okay in person you
can update me on how you're getting on
with that I am I am I am working on it
I'm working on it
I think I've got to become more
cognizant of the cost of that addiction
well exactly
to really I know one of the costs is
meaningful connections and presence with
them with and in the cost to
interpersonal relationships but
maybe I haven't had the the cost
um impact me enough yet maybe
the question left for you
but I don't know the signature so I'll
have to figure that out later but is
what's your selfish dream
um you know what I'm not sure how to sit
with that question because I'm not
trying to get out of it but I just don't
look at my own reaction to it
um
you know at this point
I don't have too many what does it mean
selfish by the way
let me ask you that what does that mean
something that
is for me at the expense of others
I don't think I have any dreams like
that left I might have not might have I
did have
at some point but if I have a dream
for myself in that sense of
self-enhancing dream something that
enhances my ego or something well if
this book sold a billion copies well
that that'd be a nice selfish dream you
know
but
I don't know how else to answer that
um I do have dreams but they're more
about
the state of the world that I like to
see the the world I'd like to see future
Generations in Arabic selfless Dreams
yeah well I don't know what this
self-loves because it certainly involves
my own history and certainly would make
me feel better you know so in that sense
it's selfish you might say but they're
not they don't have to do with personal
I have enough you know I've done enough
and I have enough so I don't have any
anything any anything lacking that I
need to dream about
all of our selfless streams are also
very much selfless selfish in that
regard as well they're going to help
themselves in a different sense I mean
any dreams I have or for a better world
certainly or certainly have the function
of making me feel better
of of maybe even
the stuff that happened to me or the
stuff that happened to you it would mean
a lot to me if they didn't happen to any
more children
you know so in the sense that it would
mean a lot to me you might say it's
selfish but it's not purely about me
it's about something larger I'm not
trying to paint myself as some kind of a
altruistic Saint I'm just saying that
would make me feel better if I really
knew that kids in Gaza didn't have to
face any more bombings if kids in Israel
didn't have to face anymore uh danger of
terrorist attacks if um not that I see
inequality there but I like that for
both of them if kids in Ukraine they
need to live under the the threat of
missiles falling
if people in Russia didn't have to feel
to live with the fear of
perhaps a nuclear conflict or the young
men being conscripted into a war
if uh if kids in Britain
you know didn't have to live in poverty
wouldn't that make you feel better you
know so to the extent that it makes us
feel better you might say it's selfish
but
is it
gabble thank you
my pleasure thank you so much thank you
so much for for writing such an
important book I I think my only wish is
that I discovered this book sooner
because I think so many of my I think it
would have liberated that's a good word
liberated me from a series of things
that would have helped me to live a much
better life and to understand myself
that's that's the point of awareness
that we talked about I know that your
Advanced stage is over isn't it yeah
I think we all want the answers even
sooner because we we reflect on some of
the consequences or the mistakes or the
that we made not that those are I'm
imprisoned by any of those but it's you
know and so it's so wonderful that this
book now exists you're you're a name
that I I started to be peppered with by
my audience over and over again
specifically in the last 12 months
people it's really really young people
were messaging me and asking me to have
a conversation with you about the topics
we've talked about today things like
ADHD and their trauma and so much and
you know I sit here every day talking to
um a lot a lot of people on this podcast
and
um I think my understanding of trauma
has forever been
redefined by both this conversation
today but also by your book and I really
I I'm so thankful to you because I think
that'll help me speak on the topic with
more accuracy
um and therefore um hopefully help other
people understand their their own trauma
in a more um meaningful way it's just
such an important book well thank you so
much thank you so much for giving me the
platform to to talk about my work and
and just the opportunity to meet you
thanks a lot and it's written in such an
accessible way yeah which is so
important because that means it can
reach even more people thank you so much
okay thank you
thank you